wir müssen uns als gesellschaft neu
aufstellen und dringend id lebenslügen
über bord werfen für die wir jetzt
gerade die quittung bekommen wir müssen
den realitäten ins auge blicken und
endlich lernen zu priorisieren was meine
ich damit zum beispiel die falsche
überzeugung dass wir nicht mehr
gefährdet sind das ist ja immer noch ein
paar jahre lang ein weit verbreiteter
glaube der dazu geführt hat zu der
situation die wir sie vorgefunden haben
natürlich brauchen wir frieden mit
russland wir brauchen aber auch schutz
vor russland in diesem können wir nur
bekommen wenn wir endlich einsehen dass
wir unsere bundeswehr auch stärken um
modernisieren müssen und dass wir sie
auch befähigen somit drei das tun zu
können was zur erfüllung ihrer aufgaben
notwendig ist so in diesem zusammenhang
müssen wir uns auch fragen wie wir uns
so abhängig machen konnten vor dem
energieträger gas also ein weiterer weit
verbreiteter glaubenssatz von dem wir
meiner meinung nach rückzug zurück
müssen denn ja die behauptungen dass es
keine einheimischen energieträger
braucht bis auf sonne und wind ist ja
absolut falsch richtig ist dass
natürlich die erneuerbaren energien
weiterhin an bedeutung gewinnen werden
aber ohne grundlastfähige energien
werden wir unser versprechen sicher
sauber und bezahlbar niemals halten
können drittens wir müssen zu guter
letzt auch mal loswerden der in diesen
irrglaube dass sämtliche
identitätsdebatte die debatten der
stunde sind und sein müssen ich kann nur
sagen ich akzeptiere alle wirklich alle
lebensentwürfe und entscheidungen des
individuums aber die die überhöhung die
klare überhöhung dieser themen bringt
uns nicht weiter ganz im gegenteil
identitätsfragen sender und andere
angeblich mega wichtige themen die
versperren den blick nummer leider auf
das was meiner meinung nach für die
zukunft unseres landes wirklich von
großer bedeutung ist das sind frieden
freiheit demokratie solide
staatsfinanzen für einen finanzierbaren
sozialstaat und sichere arbeitsplätze
spannend ja also ich weiß nicht welche
lebenslügen die deutschen sich der
einreden seit jahren tag ich glaube
nicht dass die deutschen entschieden
haben mit putin geschäfte zu machen um
billiges gas zu bekommen das nun schon
ihre politischen
entscheidungsträgerinnen und
entscheidungsträger
ich glaube auch dass ganz viele menschen
den letzten jahrzehnten gute mit
gewirtschaftet haben gewisse
entscheidungen zu treffen also ich
glaube die lebenslügen ich finde es gut
und eine politikerin sagt sie muss sich
von ihren lebenslügen befreien das find
ich gut ich bin ja auch gut dass die cdu
vielleicht beginnt einmal einen diskurs
zu gehen mit welchen lebenslügen oder
mit welchen politischen lügen sie
beschäftigen möchte aber ich würde schon
empfehlen ein bisschen zu differenzieren
zwischen den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
dem land in europa in österreich in
deutschen diese vollkommen irrelevant
und dem was jetzt die politische kaste
unter anführungszeichen und die
entscheidungsträgerinnen den letzten
jahren verbrochen haben ich sehe auch
ehrlich gesagt ich weiß das in
deutschland genau so ein großes thema
wie in österreich diese länder debatten
um so weit über die unglaublich viel
berichtet wirklich unglaublich
aufgeblasen werden wo ich aber den
großen konflikt nicht sehr ehrlich
gesagt ja ich sehe dass die menschen
ihre lebensentwürfe haben und ich sehe
jetzt nicht den grund warum wir große
debattieren müssen muss man janert oder
nicht entscheide natürlich ständig und
zwar deswegen weil sprache wirklichkeit
schauen ich kenne nicht weil denn ein
anti feministische folgen allein schon
die debatte schauen sie ich glaube als
privatpersonen können zu entscheiden wie
sie ihre text formuliert haben nicht
autoren ja großartig dann können sie das
mit ihrem verlage ausmachen oder auch
nicht aber ich persönlich finde die
debatte warum debattiert werden aber
dass die debatte haben jetzt nur
deswegen weil sie mich klar ansprechen
schaut mal darüber reden was wirklich
wichtig ist nämlich die 161 der aus
einer armen kinder in berlin über die
reden - interessant wären über das
binnen-i reden über chelsea doch machen
dass harry sie als thema habe ich
mitgebracht gebracht wir haben wir
wahrnehmen ist dasselbe thema das das
gleiche thema und ich finde es so
wichtig ich möchte sich das über ein
thema reden sondern über das thema das
die post gesprochen angesprochen hat und
das ist das thema lebenslügen und ich
finde lebenslügen und politische lügen
bedeutet dass wir scheindebatten führen
und ich glaube das ist eine
scheindebatte ich glaube das ist nicht
das was der mensch und nägeln brennt
oder wenn wir den menschen brennt nicht
unter den nägeln ob sie jetzt ändern
oder ich schon als vollkommen irrelevant
relevant
erhältliche meinung nicht die augen da
bin ich immer über nicht
hundertprozentig war ihr mann bekommt
oftmals in ein wieso widersprechen ist
doch gar nicht wieso wir schütten sie
hat sondern kommt es ist doch der punkt
ist doch dass folgender dass das was uns
oftmals medial präsentiert wird gar
nicht das ist womit sich die menschen
beschäftigen die haben ganz andere
sorgen zum beispiel so was wie habe ich
am ende des monats noch genug geld auf
dem konto sagt auch genau warum sollten
besprechen dazu tun wir gerade aber das
sollte nicht über identität sind ihr
versprechen weil am ende des tages
ich habe hauptsächlich kann man die
bodenheizung
zahlen
also rascheren also ich was ich
tatsächlich im politischen alltag
erleben dass wir eine lebenswirklichkeit
draußen in der bevölkerung haben und wir
haben eine politische lebenswirklichkeit
und diese politische lebenswirklichkeit
geht hand in hand mit der
veröffentlichten meinung und ich
versuche wirklich dafür zu werben nah
bei den menschen zu sein auch mal auf
volkes mund zu schauen ja und danach
entscheidungen zu treffen und insofern
ich würde mir wünschen dass wir politik
machen mit gesundem menschenverstand die
genau das abbildet ja uns nicht treiben
lassen uns nicht hysterisch machen
lassen keine verschwurbelten
identitätsdebatte führen und und und und
geschlechtsneutrale toiletten und was
weiß ich was es da noch so alles gibt
sondern einfach versuchen die probleme
zu lösen die wir tatsächlich haben und
vor allen dingen uns nicht den mund
verbieten sie beim namen nennen ja mal
die dinge auf den punkt bringen ja und
sie mal aussprechen schon daran
scheitert ist ja in diesem land überwog
dinge berichten wir bei bild ja auch in
der identitätspolitik jan als
ressortleiter politik wirtschaft müssen
wir da auch kritisch mit und selbst sein
als größte tageszeitung wir berichten
über die themen aber wenn man bei uns
auf die onlineseite geht wenn man will
tv schaut oder auch in die zeitung dann
wird man feststellen dass das themen
sind die wir auch behandeln aber dass es
viele viele andere themen gibt über die
wir zum teil oder in der regel auch noch
viel viel stärker
berichten und natürlich sie sprechen
themen an wie das thema armut oder das
thema verteilung das thema energie wurde
angesprochen als eine der lebenslügen
und frauchen gesagt zu recht wir müssen
gucken dass wir uns mit den sorgen und
nöten der menschen beschäftigen und ich
glaube weil du das jetzt gerade
anspruchs ist es genau das bild genau
das richtige medium beim thema energie
die große lebenslüge aus der kernkraft
auszusteigen jetzt wie ein wilder durch
die welt zu fahren und ohne zu kaufen
und gas zu kaufen anstatt zu sagen wir
lassen die drei maler die wir haben
länger laufen und die drei dinge
abgeschaltet haben bringen wir auch noch
ans netz wäre relativ einfach möglich
wird aber nicht gemacht bei der frage
weil sie immer wieder auf dieses thema
kommen kinderarmut und finde ich toll
dass sie das hier auch reinbringen
dieses mal vielleicht dann auch als die
these ist mir der ansatz den sie machen
aber zum beispiel das ist dann glaube
ich auch eine lebenslüge zu sagen wir
verteilen einfach das geld um und dann
geht es den kindern gut wir müssen dann
mal schauen warum gibt es denn dann so
viele arme kinder was ist da eigentlich
los navarro hat hat es möglicherweise
was mit dem thema bildung zu tun könnt
ja auch ist selber schuld revier kind
habe ich jetzt aber müssen sie müssen
dann wären zu hören und nicht nur
erstellen und wenn sie hierfür geradezu
gehörten habe ich gesagt hat ist
möglicherweise was mit dem thema bildung
zu tun das ist ja ein großes thema und
weise wie es in österreich ist in
deutschland eine riesen thema wenn man
sich schulabschlüsse anguckt von heute
schulabschlüsse vergleich von vor 20
jahren beispielsweise wären sie sehen
dass das bildungsniveau nicht gerade
besser geworden ist und wie sie das mit
kinderarmut zu tun können - kurz
erklären kann ich sehr gut erklären bei
menschen die beispielsweise keinen job
haben und arm sind auf hartz iv
angewiesen sender möglicherweise kinder
haben die dann schon in armut groß
werden das hat was mit bildung zu tun
das hat das mit fortbildung zu tun das
hat auch was damit zu tun ob kinder
selbst schaffen sie tun so besonders
schlau und so überlegen aber den
gedanken darf ich noch mal zu ende
bringen vielleicht weil er gar nicht von
mir stammt sondern von vielen schlauen
bildungsforschern dass auch kinder die
dann einen schulabschluss haben der aber
vielleicht gar nicht so viel wert ist
weil sie gar nicht so viel gelernt haben
wie man das eigentlich könnte im juni an
auch weniger chancen auf dem
arbeitsmarkt haben und das ist ja das
also sind die armen doch selber schon
habe ich aber dass ich gesagt habe was
jetzt gerade gesagt haben bei der
höchsten bh über die armut von kindern
sprechen über die bildung sprechen aber
mit welchen satz ich sag's welchem satz
nein schulden sie mal das ist echt eine
wirklich perfide unterstellung die sie
machen das ist hier machen ein
schlechtes bildungssystem dafür kann
doch der hartz 4 empfänger nichts dafür
kann das kind auch nichts dafür kann
wenn überhaupt warum reden wir über
bildung wenn wir über kinderarmut
sprechen sie gemacht wenn wir über armut
es gibt wieder viele
liegen genau wann war das mainufer waren
aber was macht man da was ist mit
menschen was sie gerade gewachsen habe
ich menschen reichen zwischen bildungen
guten jobs dass das muss ich sagen was
was es aber natürlich für je besser ich
ausgebildet bin ja in der regel um
barriere umso besser kann ist mein job
und wenn wir sehen das ist viel aber
nicht mehr tut werden wir sehen dass es
viele hartz vier familien gibt bei
dieser weise dann ist doch immer die
frage warum beziehen menschen hartz4 ja
wir sind hier ausgebildet sind wie gut
qualifiziert sind hier nicht gut
qualifiziert und warum leben menschen in
hartz iv und mir zu sagen weil ich über
das thema bildung rede sein bodenlose
unterstellung zu sagen ich hätte den
sozusagen gesagt sie haben selbst schuld
ist das gegenteil ist der fall das
gegenteil ist der fall der staat hat
beim thema bildung die aufgabe dafür zu
sorgen dass gerade diejenigen die aus
vielleicht für haushalten kommen denen
es sozial nicht so gut geht dafür zu
sorgen dass diese kinder ein abschluss
bekommen mit dem sie einen richtig guten
job kriegen aber das ist ja die
lebenslüge die ihr das schon wieder
dieselbe lebenslüge also entschuldigen
sie gerade wo es angesprochen die
lebenslüge zu sagen mit einer guten
ausbildung bekommt man einen guten job
und einen guten job kann man sich seine
miete leisten das ist eine lüge er stand
einfach
einfach ihren weißen
aber er kann aus krankenpflege
deutschland noch die miete in berlin
leisten ich weiß nicht vielleicht hätte
zudem besuchen grund
von jan also machen
wir noch die mieten leisten ist noch ein
anderes problem ist doch dass noch ein
ganz anderes problem das habe ich nicht
verstanden nicht schön wenn wir hier
wird für den eindruck ausbildung offen